so there I was surrounded by my friends
and all ready for my happy ever after at
least that's how I pictured it the
reality was much more single
[ __ ] off still not to dwell on the
negatives many positives to note I'm
absolutely loving my new life have tough
job at the producer of new program I'm
looking for someone dynamic to lead any
volunteers do you need the bathroom
Bridget and maintaining good
relationship with ex how are you hey
well thanks how are you I'm fine
pacifier have a whiskey please make love
shovel and my love life is showing signs
of improvement maiya it fits aside from
one tiny development I'm pregnant
everything is completely under control
sort of
it's ever look at you oh oh no Bridget
who's the father this is Mark's there's
at least fifty percent chance fifty
percent chance did you have a three-way
so this is dad I presume so yeah he
could be here this is a unique and
wonderful moment dr. Rawlings I wonder
if you could maybe give me a safer hmm
sir this is dad I presume I'm so glad
you could be here this is a unique in
marvelous men